there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock hello everybody it's us again
this is episode 147 yeah girl scout
murderers Oh going back to the true
crime man I'm doing like two different
cases the Oklahoma Girl Scout murders
which I wrote about in one of my
faceless villain volumes and also the
related well it's not really related but
the murder of Marcia Trimble which
actually happened a couple years before
the Oklahoma Girl Scout murders but I
decided to put them both together
because she was also a girl scout and
was murdered in the course of doing Girl
Scout business so I thought that would
be a good a true a true crime twofer as
they say yeah we've been doing movie
reviews all and you know all this night
and I've already been drinking so I'm
firing on all cylinders already Dennis
hasn't appeared yet early I got a
feeling Dennis might appear for news
this is a crime show and I feel like
Dennis will probably have some input on
this situation you know so defer the
first crime was actually sort of
unsolved the second one was solves but
only recently so we'll kind of get into
that in a little bit I'm looking forward
to true crime episode have you done us
see you again Jenni well thanks I guess
you know I've been keeping out I keep my
eyes out for you you know what I do
should I be worried about that oh no of
course not I mean by to church with me
we're gonna go to church me no thank you
okay so wha okay so what do we got to
talk about monetize the channel yeah
we're gonna do some shout outs before we
get to the girl scout murdering yeah
yeah so we brought this up on our last
show about Norwegian black metal but we
have decided to monetized
hasn't made a difference so far but
we'll see well we it's only been
monetized for like two days I've been
watching I watching [ __ ] I watched
those numbers I'm also i reconfigured
reconfigured some [ __ ] on my [ __ ]
knee tablet tablet okay I put one of
those it was simcha what are the call
what they call it s SIM card SIM card
tsimko yeah expand his memory
no it's gonna sound like Dennis like I
was accidentally so expand his memory so
I could juggle some [ __ ] around and I'm
I'm gonna do a 13 o'clock Instagram yeah
people were asking us about Instagram I
just thought I was gonna do it I just
haven't got around to it I'm gonna see
the best way to implement an Instagram
program you know maybe we maybe we can
get some more subscribers or something
we'll see how I'm gonna talk to my buddy
of mine who was in in the business ask
him the best way to do a little Matt you
guys in love man Matt loves [ __ ]
services to low old system buddy told me
I had old man muscle he's in a [ __ ]
war of he's an arms race with me oh my
god getting bigger faster I got 20 years
ahead of him no see he was this old man
muscle he had one of those he hammer
nose workout machines it was the Chuck
Norris workout machine with all the
[ __ ] wires that [ __ ] didn't had not
enough resistance man none of resistant
now I found that as well not enough
resist you suck but it uses your own
bodyweight there's a do man your own
bodyweight [ __ ] more resistance he
listened to me [ __ ] got big just
in like a month
walked into club he's [ __ ] swallow so
what's that little swirl and yeah I know
man I'm getting off the [ __ ] subject
I'm drunk I'm talking this is bad you
guys he's drunk at the beginning of this
show okay man because like I said this
is the second thing like we recorded a
movie really so we'll see if he's even
like coherent at that although probably
just be waving his arms around just like
when I'm driving you know talking about
it right then
all right submit that on camera I'm
driving I rise to the occasion I just
stay focus you know just watch
lines we'll see how that goes at one
time he came back to strip club I don't
know how I [ __ ] made it a couple
years back my dad [ __ ] I'm like
everybody went we had this battle of the
[ __ ] bands now not battle the man's
battle of the Bark's they had although
the bartender's and our bartenders was
you know it was one of our it was one of
our favorite part invite us all over to
Rachel's is his [ __ ] high class
didn't very very famous very famous
drugged up so we were down there man we
just got like a sloshed half of us I'm
talking about there was a lot of people
that half of us slept in the damn
parking lot I fell asleep in the
backseat of the car I made it back man I
thought I was I thought I was looking
through a [ __ ] toilet paper tube
driving bad with just one night all this
left my credit card there yeah I was
growling the whole way back I went out
to the car to get something in the car
and fell asleep okay strippers
everywhere
strippers loved it well no because I
love this I remember that night fondly
actually because one thing if you've
never been to strip clubs yeah one thing
about strip clubs that maybe a lot of
people don't know is that the strippers
[ __ ] love it because they're so she's
got these big-ass boobs I used to like
doing with like yeah well one there so
you still like dealing with creepy ass
dudes all the time yeah and so it's
probably like a nice change they're like
hey girl hooray it was and they will
tell you like all their problems they
will like you're my sister we're all got
down [ __ ] yeah they super yes and all
that and you know I don't know little
cami was there she's dressed up as a cat
if you guys ever seen a lead a battle
angel that's what cami looks like looks
just like this she just looks just like
that she's like every time I was
watching that movie I'm like that's
awesome that looks just like she's like
four foot eight and like he comes with
cat ears that add ten pounds to the cat
ears big-ass [ __ ] can use any way you
guys get back all right so like I
monetize the channel yes
I'm hopefully it's not you know
inconvenience in anybody we're gonna see
that gives us anything out
[ __ ] algorithms I don't know if it'll
make a difference it doesn't make it
we'll see like I said it's an experiment
we're seeing if it makes all we're
trying to do necessarily because I know
that it doesn't I mean you need like 50
s quintillion B is before you make any
money off it but what we're trying to do
is see if YouTube promotes us or rises
up in the algorithm algorithm so that
like you know we have more views more
yeah subscribers we're just seeing if
you are new to the show you don't
understand the format Jenny and I
[ __ ] talk to the regulars first
before you know it if you don't like it
just [ __ ] unsub you [ __ ] out here
take us a few minutes and we have to get
fired up before the show starts and we
just have to give people news and stuff
um so Instagram is probably common I'm
gonna figure out the best way to do not
it's gonna be working on and get some
good graphics and everything come on
beyond that [ __ ]
if it's gonna be worth it I'm gonna see
we'll see yeah people have requested it
also new shirts are coming ok Jenny's
gonna design the silkscreen I'm going to
execute the silkscreen I was doing it
since I was an idiot bitty baby back
before back when your mama was a baby
screens back when I was in high school
we did still screen the old wait throw
it [ __ ] down at em time to scream with
squeegee and go do life but it's a it's
the best shirt you can money can [ __ ]
him by because that that that paint goes
inside that material and it never comes
out some of this [ __ ] that that that
they're making now I'm not satisfied
with how long that it lasts and I want
our products to be the best and it also
they're cheaper for us to produce and we
can pass on savings to you I don't think
I don't think that that shirt will break
$20 well like I said I wanted something
that I could send out to our $20 nut
patrons in our contest winner every
quarter without it costing cuz I think
last time when I said stuff from Seattle
I think it ended up costing me like
almost $300 so yeah that's average and I
want to be able to sell it off eBay
yeah everybody everybody has the eBay
account and I wanted more to be able to
be like 19
nine with Plus even with the shipping
included we'll see how it goes but
they'll look like this there'll be one
color white all black
yes that's traditional and Jenny's going
to do the designs there's new ways of
making silk screens so you can get
really good details and stuff I'm gonna
do with how is it done now Jenny well
you have to send it to all unless you
have prayer at home which I know well
you send it to a printer and get a print
printed on a transparency and then you
burn it on to a screen with okay photo
emulsion back in the old days we used to
trace it out and cut it but that's the
old-fashioned way yeah there's a better
way of doing it that gives you a better
image and we're gonna use that way but
you know I got two garages and build
motorcycles and [ __ ] like that and
[ __ ] places to work out I can sit
there and knock out shirts to order and
they're gonna look cool the back I'll
have a little logo me and Jenny in the
back and the front will be a theme yeah
and our subscriber subscribers who are
20 and up will get one every quarter
yeah patrons excuse me yeah we're gonna
do a different one every quarter
different one every quarter so it'll be
different every time and we'll also make
them available on YouTube for purchase
yeah on ebay on ebay yeah yeah I'm
[ __ ] up I'm inner inner webbing Oh
told you guys that's fine on all
cylinders talk about these Girl Scouts
who got murdered what else do we have
before shout-out I would like to give a
shout-out to friend of the show Rob who
sent us a DVD today of the thing that's
equal the sequel to thing yeah it's it's
a good one I've seen it yes we saw in
the theater actually yeah I was on the
theater and I actually I really really
liked it love the first one head crustle
cross what was any of you guys know know
who the Christ you're not regulars you
have a crush on Russell is fresh with
Russell it also has to do the crush like
mad crush yes and it's it's all straight
don't worry about it's all straight it's
all heterosexual uh-huh something
sometimes
I wasn't okay I mean the proof of
greatness is one one man can recognize
the greatness of another man yes Danny
I recognize the greatness of crustle I
gotcha hi guys he's in the new Quentin
Tarantino movie or you don't want to see
that of course it looks pretty good
actually after I like Brussels and Santa
Claus that's how much I like Crosley
that was a good movie Christmas
Chronicles we present a con we talked
about that on one of our Chris gotta do
you got a do review that was a good what
is like kind of a crotchety cynic who's
a badass
yeah like that it was a Santa that could
possibly could be carrying a gun you
don't know I would actually kind of be
disappointed if he wasn't good like down
the back of his pants yeah and like you
didn't know it's like he didn't say
anything about it but like you give him
any lip and he's just like butch funk
and he's just like [ __ ] whips it out
yeah it's a 1911 bad you found I braved
it's engraved with Christmas motif on it
you know with like oh it's all in its
got like a little snowman's of [ __ ] no
man cakes
it's got [ __ ] reindeer horn grips
it's got [ __ ] it's got a [ __ ]
mistletoe and gravy and [ __ ] all in
there man [ __ ] right I got it all
figured out
Tom hands an active fantasy life as you
can see he's already picturing Christmas
themed
yeah guns yeah Russell 1911 yeah to
carry around
yeah well tom is sick Sawyer [ __ ]
we're talking the original coal in the
waistband elastic waistband of yeah in a
series 70 yeah oh goodness but yeah cold
dealt a leat 10 millimeter yeah [ __ ]
scrolled out like that yeah nineteen all
right I don't know how did we get off on
that tape we were just we were just
thanking Rob thank you very much for
sending us thank you very much the
sequel of the thing cuz that was like a
kick ass movie we saw in the theater
yeah we will probably be reviewing it
sometime in the next few months we got a
lot of [ __ ] on the list will do yeah we
do because I just bought like a bunch of
DVDs and also shudder
added a bunch of stuff that I would like
to do reviews of such as Carrie and
ghost story and some other ones so those
will probably be coming up as well but I
also I bought a big pile of DVDs and I
got to work through those too so if I
don't get to it I mean I'll get to it
the next few months I promise all right
so let's talk about let's do the
Oklahoma Girl Scout murders first okay
now show is getting ready to begin so
while you're on your commute or if
you're in bed okay you cuddle up cuddle
up [ __ ] just kind of roll up inside
the comforter alright put your
headphones on alright if you're a bit if
you're in your commute just look out the
window of the train or firmly grip the
wheel I was gonna drive don't look at
your go ahead good good look because I
was gonna say just I'm on this ride too
that just reminded me that like there's
there's one thing that really bothers me
in movie scene and it's whatever
characters that are driving a car turn
to the passenger and have like an
extended conversation with the pet I'm
like watch the road people drive and
then I'm in the backseat and they turn
Michael look at me right watch the road
stop it oh my god it only takes like two
[ __ ] seconds not even two seconds
come on now yeah yeah [ __ ] crazy
mm-hmm alright really every time that I
see that in the movie that like drives
me [ __ ] crazy okay let's get dishes
alright so this show this show is about
Girl Scouts they were murdered yeah what
are they all unsolved the first case is
unsolved okay the second one was solved
but not until recently okay three made
you just talk with Girl Scout stuff well
the Oklahoma Girl Scout murders is
actually a really famous unsolved case
and I wrote about it for one of my books
okay and somebody a long time ago asked
me about the Marcia Trimble murder and
she was also a girl scout so I thought
well I'd put them both together on one
show because like I said they're not
otherwise related but the girls that
were the victims were all Girl Scouts I
understand thanks Dennis I'll be here
with you
okay okay I'll be on this journey with
you Jenny
okay to make sure that you you tell us
right okay okay that that's good oh well
of course I'm in charge you know I'm
making sure that you're gonna deliver
that story and and what are you gonna do
to me if I don't do it right
[Laughter]
Dennis [ __ ] on me all party Raider
Dennis Rader Dennis Rader buy it appear
at any [ __ ] moment really don't even
[ __ ] turn your ass inside out come on
out I'm the only man that can channel
the spirit of Dennis Rader while Dennis
Rader still alive unfortunately alright
so let's talk about the Oklahoma Girl
Scout murders now this happened in 1977
if you would like to see a kind of
extensive look into the case
I found a documentary on YouTube earlier
today which is called someone cry for
the children and it's narrated by Johnny
[ __ ] cash I think you say Johnny Depp
no okay
much cooler than Johnny Depp Johnny
[ __ ] cash yeah because I started
watching it like I wasn't really paying
attention because it was doing something
else I'm like god that sounds like
Johnny Cash's voice and then like it
says narrated by John that was the
original Glen dancing yeah yeah well
yeah so he'd narrates a documentary but
it's like an hour and a half long
so and it has like a lot of interviews
with the the parents of the victims and
you know various people that worked on
the case so I'm gonna check that out you
can go check that out so do you posted
on YouTube earlier so alright so it's
the summer of 1977 now there is this
Girl Scout camp and it was called Camp
Scott it's in northeastern Oklahoma in
Mays County and what they would do is
they would have like all the little girl
scouts come for like two weeks at a time
like during the summer and they would
like to you know outdoor [ __ ] like Girl
Scouts do I mean I was in the Girl
Scouts when I was little so it's like
you don't you go out there you tie knots
make fires you know we buy the cookies
every [ __ ] year - Thin Mint cookies
well clearly Thin Mints are the best
it's like a little yeah
finding the ones with the coconut rush
the other ones it's the Samoa Samoas
yeah hell yes they just crush the other
hell yeah do they even have other ones
they do there they're all good they had
the peanut butter ones - oh come on the
peanut butter ones were okay yeah yeah
[ __ ] it really good you ever chocolate
you know serious people don't these
British people don't understand
odd noise I'm always driving [ __ ]
brick behind peanut butter every time I
run across a [ __ ] red coat he doesn't
like peanut butter damn it
but no you better buy some Girl Scout
cookies I'm giving a shout-out to the
Girl Scouts telling y'all buy some
goddamn Girl Scout cookies they're good
as [ __ ] man
they're fantastic frozen well especially
if it's been man 1 I mean I could eat
seriously I could eat a whole sleeve of
the Thin Mints like frozen Thin Mints I
will lead a whole sleeve of that no
shame oh yeah
and also they make that ice cream word
they're like they know what they're
doing they know what they do know and I
should say that when I was a Girl Scout
many many many many years ago one of our
things that we did when we did the
cookie sales we actually went
door-to-door but I didn't really like
doing that because I you know I have
social anxiety but um I don't like going
to strangers [ __ ] houses trying to
sell cookies I'm like [ __ ] that they
could be murderers you know how I am but
uh we actually had a booth that we set
up at the mall which was the Belushi
mall which is in Daytona Beach still
there as far as I know and so we set it
up and we stalked it out with cookies
and then we were like selling them to
people that were coming through the mall
now I should say that the Thin Mints
easily they just demolished all the
competition we ran out of Thin Mints at
9:00 a.m. yeah they're good and then
like the resting everybody would come up
like 99% of people came up again any
thin mints no they're all small in case
you [ __ ] off peace you foreign savages
don't know what [ __ ] bin mint cookies
are these
[ __ ] dead chocolate cookies covered
in chocolate but their chocolate and
mint take a genuine - honestly chocolate
admit you're like I'm making a chocolate
in a little wafer there good man
but the other ones are good - the peanut
butter ones are good also like I said
thin man's are like way in the front
Samoas or my second Samoas there's
something kind of that have like the
flaked coconut they're crispy on the
bottom but they're chewy at the same
time it's a cookie with coconut kind of
like I don't remember it's like the
filling from a from a from a mounds
candy bar with chocolate running stripes
chocolate stripes and [ __ ] yeah yeah I
said I'm gonna say I mean if you really
like just being chewy at the same time
in coconutty that should we go great
with rum well yes
I'll just dunk them in ROM like we're
just stuck with dumpling you know yeah
you know me because you get the
chocolate chip cookies and you tuck them
in milk yeah you get those damn Samoas
and dunk them in [ __ ] wrong I better
be good
now the Thin Mints are good dipped in
car or Malibu you can tuck them in man
oh yeah better yeah much better
yeah The Thin Mints you guys if you
didn't know when it's not Girl Scout
cookie season which if you're not from
the United States I don't know if you
have Girl Scouts over whatever wherever
you are but um you know there's only a
certain season that they sell cookies
and if you don't go buy some Keebler
grasshoppers they're pretty much exactly
the same I mean the Girl Scouts they
caught they charge a lot for the cookies
but it's you know it's for a good cause
it's so funny because our show you know
we cover these kind of topics all in
everybody listened to but everybody
knows that we always get sad so you
start talking about food or music I feel
that like what everybody says yeah do
something more that sidetrack [ __ ] when
I what I was like when I was thinking
about doing this topic I said I know
we're gonna get off on this whole
tangent about girls girls go I know we
are
nobody has to lemon wants to
they have lemon Wednesday right I know
that sunshine had them damn a lemon
coolers you know I love lemon [ __ ] man
I'm all about that I'm a child of the
south and so is Jenny you know the
heaviest damn [ __ ] thinks sunshine
made a scene called lemon coolers and
they were like a round about that big
and there's a fantastic cook e with
powdered sugar on like a wedding cookie
but with yeah and instead chocolate
chips in there and have lemon chips and
that [ __ ] would [ __ ] you up man I mean
just they were you know you just
couldn't stop eating them that's why
southern this is so [ __ ] fat we know
what to eat you know it's a constant war
against fat tell him Jenny preach it
brother
don't [ __ ] you know I'm right here with
you it is we know how to eat it's a
struggle now the struggle is real right
well begun you know it's like there's so
much it's like World War 3 the Battle of
the [ __ ] fat all right so let's stop
talking about cookies I'm hungry all
right we're talking about serious [ __ ]
you ready I'm ready but you make me
think of going to Captain D's and get
all that [ __ ] fried fish goddamn
that's it we're gonna take a video next
time we go to next captain eat that
[ __ ] southern [ __ ] eat right five
fried fish with the hush puppies and
they would love that [ __ ] show them that
okay we gotta get back this subject I
gotta get I'm just firing on all
cylinders my turbocharged right now
turbocharged several chars I'm going
down a road book on sorry yeah okay I
gotta take over Jenny I don't thinking
about food all right take over I gotta
rest all right we're going back to the
summer of 1977 this is an Oklahoma now
there is a Girl Scout camp called Camp
Scott and all the little Girl Scouts go
there's for about ages 8 to 18 they go
there and they every summer they have
different ones they go there like every
two weeks and they have like a bunch of
that they call them tents but they were
actually kind of like a tent top and
then the base part of it was like a
wooden floor so it was like a permanent
wooden floor with like a tent top
over it so it wasn't just like a tent
like on the ground or whatever so they
have like a bunch of those in this
particular camp so this is uh this a 410
acre camp camp Scott so this is June 12
1977 so there are about 140 girls and
they take off from this place called the
magic Empire Council building which is
in Tulsa Oklahoma they all get on a bus
and they go out to it's about a 40 50
mile journey out to Camp Scott
so the camp is in ten different like
little units or whatever they want to
call them odds yeah pretty much
so they bring they separated all the
girls like depending on their age
because like I said some of the girls
were really young there were only like
eight or nine years old and some of them
were like older like oldest back when I
went to Bible study camp and I was a kid
man we did you I didn't know that yeah
oh hell yeah
I never went first time I ever go out
with a girl at Bible Camp yeah yeah you
guys don't understand man [ __ ] Bible
study camp it was all just a bunch of
teenagers they were all kind of trying
to get it on so we're all the counselors
it was like Straight Outta [ __ ]
Friday 13th really I was gonna except
y'all didn't get murdered with a mission
know that but at the plus I I had fun
man I was you know I think I've heard
that about those lamps I was like
probably about 11 and my kiss and girl
is about 12 other woman yeah yeah I
guess a girl's about 12 and on the bus
oh I thought you were gonna say on the
button now but then once I cooled off
and everything I was I was I was I was
too shy to go up and talk to her again
you know talking about I was like ya
know I can't talk to her and I just
can't stir history is like day before
yeah yeah I understand that yeah it's a
well I've killed all kids are like that
it's pretty universal
yeah all right so the the one camp that
we're going to be or the one unit or pod
or whatever that we're discussing in
this in this case was called Kiowa Kiowa
I guess was how you pronounce it um now
it was kind of like
one of the most kind of remote of all
the ten units it was kind of there was
sort of forest around it and stuff now
at this point on this particular trip
there were about twenty seven girls in
this one unit and there were seven
different tents now you were kind of
like depending on how old you were you
know they kind of gave you a little
roommates depending on you know the
girls ages so they go they put four
girls per tent
but in tent number eight which was the
tent that we're gonna be talking about
there was only three girls and this tent
in particular was the only one that
could not be seen from the counselors
tent because there was like a it was
like a building that had showers in it
and it was kind of like blocking the
view of it so it was kind of like the
most remote tent it was like the last in
the row so it's June 12th the evening
that they got there um you know they'd
arrived by bus now the three girls that
were in this particular tent they were
named Laurie Doris and Michelle and they
hadn't known each other previously but
since they were roommates they kind of
started making friends with each other
and whatnot laurie farmer was only eight
years old
and Doris Milner was 10 years old
Michelle kousei was nine years old so
the three of them are in this one
particular tent which was ten number
eight now it's about 6:00 p.m. the girls
had dinner then they all go back to
their tents and then there's really
really big storm like comes through the
area and the counselors told all the
girls to kind of stay in their tents
it's like why don't you you know write
letters to your moms or whatever because
you can't really go outside because the
weather was too bad so they're all kind
of stuck in their tents now later that
same night because I guess they the
storm had gone on for a long time and
they were all kind of confined to their
tents at that point so several hours
later a bunch of people started
reporting hearing like some weird noises
like back in the woods like some of them
said it sounded kind of like croaking
like a bullfrog type that are like a
bullhorn or like a combination of those
two things they kept hearing these weird
like croaking noises back in the woods
they also started seeing these like
lights like it was a flashlight that was
flashing but then like you would flash
your flashlight into the woods and that
it would go off you know what I mean
like someone was kind of back there
watching them hmm
so they thought that was kind of strange
but no one really thought that much
about it at the time
now as the night went on some girls also
later reported that they had heard a
little girl crying and that they had
heard someone calling for their mother
but they didn't really do anything about
it because they thought oh well the
counselors will take care of it or you
know they couldn't really tell where it
was coming from and it was kind of like
far away yeah in case anybody doesn't
can't really imagine what the hell's
going on these kind of these kind of
[ __ ] events in the United States and
the one that I went to is probably in
the very late seventies okay um there's
a festive environment
yeah and it's constant activity so it
would be kind of hard to differentiate
between something of a serious some
people just [ __ ] around young because
it'd be okay when I when I went to Bible
study camp which is very similar to kind
of situation there was no Bible there
was no study involved in it there's more
about just [ __ ] Easter egg hunts yeah
let's think of songs are running around
playing with flashlights at night he
[ __ ] like that and having like
counselors pull pranks on you yeah I
feel like that's all it was like it was
fun it was fun and little groups were
doing different things at different
times depending on what the age groups
was I was probably one of the younger
age groups I think there was some older
ones above me and they were doing things
are a little more sophisticated than
what we could do yeah I'm talking about
yeah good you know I guess I was
probably kind of grouped up with the
little kids you know at that time I was
probably terilyn even though you were
going after older women even she was in
the same group as me
some little girl that was on the bus
with me you know I mean I wish a big
boobies I was chubby and she was chubby
no but I remember I can't barely
remember you know what I mean yeah but
everybody was doing that got [ __ ] well
that's the thing too and I maybe was
[ __ ] trying to make out yeah and I
feel like you know particularly in camp
situations like this I mean this was all
little girls and as far as I don't know
if any the counselors were male I think
that all the counselors were female I
mean all the interviews with counselors
that I've seen about in documentaries
about this they've all been women but um
it seems to me men knew that this event
was going down though I'll tell you that
well well this was a this was a Girl
Scout camp it was there every summer
like you know different groups of Girl
Scouts would come like over the course
of some dude knew about this well yeah
that's pretty much what they're thinking
but another thing too is that even when
you're camping out in the woods and
stuff and you hear weird noises like
you're you're croaking noise or even
here crying or something like that
you know some people like oh why didn't
they do it like you know in hindsight
you're wondering like why didn't anybody
do anything about it but it's in a big
group of little kids there's always a
bunch of different noise going that's
maybe there's a lot of different things
it's like your mind doesn't I mean
happily because usually it doesn't
happen but your mind doesn't immediately
jump to someone's getting murdered right
it's also because that's a very rare
occurrence it was very different time
for any you young true thank you
youngsters we [ __ ] grew up as like
feral kids it was a very different time
people weren't worried in a million we
weren't really pampered yeah [ __ ] I was
a little kid going down in the goddamn
[ __ ] flood control system of
California nowhere they [ __ ] this
film
Terminator 2 you know yeah yeah I wasn't
playing in there and I wouldn't even
supposed to but we did it anyway well
yeah I mean you know I mean we were
going back in the woods setting shuttle
commander woodshed [ __ ] on fire
given gasoline our lawn mowers it was on
fire did it it was sucking dangerous to
be a boy back in those
in that area but it was normal I felt
through a damn fish tank [ __ ] legs up
yeah yeah stood up on top fish tank
where they were squirting with the hose
not broke through it me all up good give
me all the kind of stitches we did all
kinds of cool well well it's not it's
not I was like I was like seven or eight
yeah I was like seven or eight when that
happened yeah kids do dumb [ __ ] all the
time yeah we had we grew up in a very
different way it was very third-world
very man of action tight [ __ ] well
y'all are the kind of kids cuz I think
my brothers might have done this too but
it's like you know where it's like oh
man I can't take the blanket off my bad
tire on my neck and pretend I'm Superman
off the roof hey get that shotgun sir
you know I mean get your dad's shotgun
yep
yeah [ __ ] right shoot up the [ __ ]
house you know and your which is I would
imagine to a lot of people maybe in
Newton in the New England area the
United States or maybe in Europe or in
other countries that this would be just
unfathomable that an eight-year-old boy
could go get his dad shot gun and just
shoot shoot up the [ __ ] woods and dad
why he was shooting yeah we shouldn't
okay but we should not to shoot anybody
in the face you shooting okay yeah she
just was you know well that's how we
were raised
yeah all right so as I said all this
weird should have been going on in the
night but no one really thought all that
much about it now the following morning
it was fairly early I think it was only
was it between 6:00 and 7:00 in the
morning so one of the camp counselors
gets up and she's going toward the
building with the showers in it and then
she sees something it looked like part
of a sleeping bag that was kind of
laying at the edge of the tree line so
she thought that was kind of weird so
she goes over there to look at it and
then what she sees by the sleeping bag
is Doris Milner the ten year old and she
is laying there obviously dead laying
outside the sleeping bag well obviously
obviously dead just was she cut up
she was um she had been beaten okay and
they would later determined that all of
the girls had also been raped so they
were yeah they were all messed up so
they're laying there with their sleeping
bags and why not so they called the cops
the cops come and kind of look around
the area and they find the other two
girls that were in the same tent Laurie
and Michelle and they were also kind of
next to their sleeping bags [ __ ]
savage did it yeah yeah now all three
girls were sexually assaulted I've seen
varying sources on this I think at least
one of them was sodomized I'm not I
think it was Doris but please don't
quote me on that because I'm not sure
but um the other ones were raped for
sure now Michelle and Doris also had had
their wrists tied behind their backs and
had gags in their mouths
although Laurie who was the youngest
when she was only eight years old she
had not been bound her gagged now
Michelle had been strangled
but her yeah I think Michelle had been
strangled
one of them was strangled see I'm sorry
and then the other two had been beaten
to death in the head
they had blunt-force trauma to the head
see I'm sorry I just have to kill about
furger like that I'm sorry well I don't
think anyone would blame cut that
[ __ ] head off I don't not with
the sword would like that something like
a pocketknife I'd cut that well yeah it
would have to be you would have to make
them suffer I mean I can't just like
talking to him is doing that you that's
what I mean I mean something like this
yeah you kind of want to have to do are
just like cut his pieces on star I don't
understand the whole concept of mercy
these are little girls and this is not
someone that I mean I don't think I've
never seen anybody say that this is not
a meet those new children man these are
people's children these girls that
they're not old enough to even [ __ ]
know anything very innocent he buys us I
just can't understand I can't fathom I
couldn't even fathom mercy on somebody
who did that just know and like I said
there's no I mean I'm not saying that
there's ever a reason to do anything
like this but there was never it was
completely random they're out there
having fun and [ __ ] yeah they're just
dead this can
this was their first night at the camp
they'd never been a Girl Scout camp
before they were all excited about going
Oh mother [ __ ] face off first I just
can't stand it
Yeah right yeah and he's just like you
know I mean these girls have you aren't
even old no - who lived the life yet
yeah you know I mean this would be a
time of innocence yes even you could go
to [ __ ] a maximum-security prison in
the United States and tell those
[ __ ] what this guy did and they
would be outraged yeah that's maybe like
it's like even like who did that
wouldn't convicts would kill your ass
for that yeah this is not gonna fly no
these are three adorable precious girls
just hanging out of the Girl Scout camp
just sleeping in a tent there's a storm
there relate Brighton letters to their
moms and you know what sucks is like I
saw a documentary about this and like
the mob still has the letter that the
little girl wrote to her said in the in
the tent like just a couple hours first
you got [ __ ] raped and murdered yeah
that's [ __ ] horrible I've got a
feeling I got a feeling this is a young
dude maybe a teenager um they're not
entirely sure who did it they they have
their suspicions but I I'm not gonna say
I don't know if I know it was this dude
or not but you know well gets man there
are adult men that have been known to do
[ __ ] like this yeah they're [ __ ]
mentally yeah they're mentally children
ones that do a lot of it you know their
developments [ __ ] up but yeah there's
something about this that makes me think
I mean it's just my feelings dad whoever
did this wasn't really that much older
than these girls maybe we're talking
about 16 17 year old guy maybe that's my
instincts go ahead good all right maybe
wrong so after these three little girls
were found murdered um the creepy thing
is that I mean I don't know if it's
creepy because I guess that's probably
what they would do but they didn't call
they didn't tell the rest of the girls
at the camp that the three of them had
been murdered
they just said hey we're gonna do some
activities over here today and then
they very they said then we're gonna get
on the bus and we're gonna go back to
Tulsa and we're gonna call your parents
and say something went wrong and you
guys all have to go home now the shitty
thing too was that when they first
contacted these little girl's parents
about what had happened they didn't tell
them that they'd been murdered they just
said oh there was an accident quoting
love so they didn't tell them and and
honestly I don't think they realized
that they had even been like raped and
murdered until a lot later that's rough
man
that's what I mean it's like can you
imagine oh no I could imagine I can
imagine that's [ __ ] very rough though
that's yeah it's could you imagine being
a [ __ ] parent and find this [ __ ] out
so I'm saying it makes me want to carve
that muhfuckas face off yeah that's what
I mean that just not only does it
destroy that child that destroys them it
destroys the parents you know yeah well
and honestly like I don't have you know
I don't have children but I've heard and
I completely would agree with the fact
that losing a child is like the worst
thing that could ever happen I only have
a cat we have a cat that's gonna kill
that we at if somebody killed baby cook
on it I would [ __ ] kill you because I
could I could imagine what it would be
like if it was that's what I mean and
she's not even a person yeah but
somebody did somehow a human person you
know I mean she's a cat person but but
if somebody my cat I would [ __ ] kill
you that's what I mean no I can imagine
like how much worse it would be for like
a person that's that's Tom by accident
accidents happen but if you kill my cat
I'll perfect [ __ ] kitty it's what I
would do yeah I'm just telling
everything sure nobody would find out
well I think before I think a lot of
people feel that way about their animals
though well you know it's like I don't
have a kid but it's like so I can
imagine it would be that much worse cuz
it's so if that's my cat I would not
only kill you I would make a stew out of
you and eat you damn
damn 10 Jenny's going way up here I'm
just saying I don't like that eat dead
piece of [ __ ] although I could season
the [ __ ] out of that and I wouldn't feel
bad about it either I just telling you
right now I'm just I'm just trying to
put in perspective you know man yeah I
see it from from the parents point of
view the [ __ ] rage I would feel yeah
no I don't think about it that's what I
mean oh my god I know I don't want to go
down a rabbit yeah you probably don't
cuz I can't like I said I I can't I
can't imagine I can but I can't you know
what I'm saying I can imagine I don't
want to yeah you probably don't want to
imagine now the weird thing about this
is that about two weeks before the
murders occurred um another counselor at
Camp Scott had reported that someone had
broken into her cabin and it's stolen
some stuff including like some
eyeglasses and a couple of other kind of
like minor things
now another weird thing that happened at
this time was that there had been she
had like a box of donuts and I guess it
had donuts in it but when she found the
box
it was empty like someone had taken all
the donuts or eaten them
but they'd left a note in there and the
note said now I've seen varying accounts
of this the note either said that four
girls will be murdered at the camp over
the summer or three girls will be so
someone was planning this now as I said
this was two weeks before the murder now
so because you find a note like that in
a [ __ ] donut box in your cabin where
someone's stolen your glasses and stuff
they didn't really take it all that
seriously because they thought it was
just a joke so they didn't report it
until later on you know what I mean
because they're just like okay whatever
it's like somebody left a note in a
[ __ ] donut box and ate all my donuts
so they just so she just threw the note
of wind didn't think any more about it
now okay so after the murder of these
three little girls took place it was
kind of like a [ __ ] show because they
sort of yeah
they kind of got the area cordoned off
around the bodies but other than that
that was kind of like people tramping
all over the camp it's like so you know
it was really hard to like collect
evidence because there was just people
everywhere and it's like a circus
atmosphere as you know a lot of [ __ ]
around then was um also you know it was
the 1970s it was 1977 so you didn't have
like a lot of you know good forensic
evidence such as DNA evidence and all
that other kind of stuff now they did
find that in the tent like I said I'm
calling it a tent but I've seen pictures
of it and it's just at the top of it was
a tent the base part of it was like a
wooden base and like a wooden floor with
like a tent top over it so inside that
they found some bloody footprints it was
like a military boot so they did find
that you know what size we were talking
about um it was actually a little bit of
a smaller size I think it was only a
seven or eight maybe or maybe a nine it
was just like it was it was a similar
size so it Samantha it was a man size
but not a big it wasn't like a big
[ __ ] he wasn't a large into it no no
no oh that you could be talking about 13
14 year old - yeah but like I said I'll
get in - okay all right so now because
there was blood found inside the tent
and this food and this footprint was
found inside the tent they were assuming
that the girls were first attacked
inside the tent and then carried out
because they were found about 150 yards
outside of the tent which means they
must have been carried out of the tent
after being attacked or at some point
during the attack which I'll get into
what I think that implies a little bit
later
they also found a flashlight that had a
fingerprint on the lens
they found a crowbar and they found some
pieces of black duct tape and a long
black hair now there were a couple
suspects they had in mind the first guy
that they looked into was this guy named
Jack Shroff and he
owned a ranch that wasn't far from Camp
Scott now when they searched his home
they found a roll of black duct tape and
they also found some rope which looked
very much like the rope that had been
used to bind two of the girls wrists now
when they questioned him about the [ __ ]
that they had found at this house he
said well what happened was that someone
broke into his ranch and they stole a
bunch of stuff including rope and tape
and some other things like that and he's
like so I just bought these to like
replace what this guy had stolen did he
report it um he may have but they did
interview him they interviewed him over
the course of a couple of days and he
also had a pretty airtight alibi for the
time of the murder so they thought that
probably he had done he also took a
polygraph and he passed it so they
because this sounds kind of like likely
that the offender would probably steal
some [ __ ] so we're talking about kind of
a vagrant or a yeah yeah somebody who's
transient well I'm gonna get into that
right now so that was the first suspect
that they had he was he was cleared he
had an alibi he passed a polygraph and
whatnot now we're gonna talk about the
most famous that the most famous suspect
in this case and like I said I'm not
coming down for or against because I
wasn't there I don't really know if he
did it or not cuz some [ __ ] really
sounds like he did it in some [ __ ] not
so much the next suspect that they
looked into was this guy named Jean
Leroy
Hart now he was um a Cherokee and lived
in the area
his mom lived only about a mile away
from Camp Scott and he had had some past
criminal convictions of some similar
kind of crime okay it's starting to
sound like now he had um already done
okay so the first time that he was
imprisoned he had raped two pregnant he
kidnapped two pregnant women and tied
them up put tape over their faces like
all over their whole faces raped them
then
kind of took them out somewhere and
dumped them and left them like expecting
that they would die I suppose but they
didn't actually one of them escaped and
went and got help and so they both lived
now uh Jean Leroy Hart was captured for
this but he escaped they put him in
prison but he escaped then um he was in
prison that he gets out on parole at
some point and then he was captured
again for robbery now he got another
sentence for that but then he escaped
from jail again and they couldn't find
him for a really long time and this was
back in the early 70s like 1972 1973 as
I said the Oklahoma Girl Scout murders
happened in 1977 so he was still like on
the loose at this time and he was
thought to live somewhere around that
area where Camp Scott was an Oklahoma
now the interesting thing about this
like I said he was a Cherokee and so
like a lot of people that lived in this
a lot of the native Native Americans
that lived in this area of Cookson
County um they knew him and like vouch
for him like what an awesome dude he was
now around the time of the murders or a
couple days after it happened there were
these hunters and they were kind of you
know exploring in the area that was not
far away from the camp and they find
this cave and this cave looks like
somebody's been living in it inside the
cave they find some photographs of women
which they think that Jean Leroy Hart
might have had when he was in prison
like that were up on his wall or
whatever they also found some pairs of
eyeglasses which were similar to the
ones that had been stolen from the
counselors cabin at the camp Scott and
they also found like some old newspapers
now it should be noted that the
flashlight that was found at Camp Scott
after the murder of the three Girl
Scouts had some crumpled up newspaper
like found in it or around it that was
from the same day as that
newspaper that they found in the cave
they also found in the cave this little
note that said 77 617 June 17 1977
although the date is reversed which
isn't how an American would write it
which seems kind of weird but it said
that and then it said the real killer
was here bye bye fools so that was found
on the wall at the Cape now um by the
time they found this cave they figured
that Jean Leroy Hart had been living in
this cave because they knew that that
was like the pictures at least were his
stuff but they didn't know where he had
gone subsequently so then they find out
from an informant that he's been staying
with this other guy who was named pigeon
and that was 50 miles away from Camp
Scott so they go to pigeons house and
Jean Leroy Hart is indeed there so
allegedly they asked him there like did
you kill the three girls at the Girl
Scout camp and he says quote you'll
never pin it on me according to the cops
that's what he said and then after that
he says he's not gonna talk anymore now
weirdly what happened with this whole
thing was that it seemed like and and
they went into this a little bit on the
documentary that I was talking about
earlier that had Johnny Cash narrated
was that a lot of the people in the
Cherokee community in the area at the
time like knew Jean Lee Lee Roy Hart and
thought that he was innocent and that he
was being railroaded and in fact they
said that a lot of the [ __ ] that was in
the cave was planted by law enforcement
so I don't know if that's true or not
that's just saying what they what they
said they said that he was being
railroaded by the cops and that he was
really a great guy and that he would
never have done such a thing right so
there's that mole controversy so it
seemed like in the community there was a
lot of support for Jean Lee Roy Hart and
I remember like some of
the parents of the little girls that
were murdered we're saying you know
you'd go into a restaurant in the area
at the time and there would be like a
jar like raising money for Jean Leroy
Hart's defense because they thought he
was innocent so they wanted like to help
him out there's some domestic trial
there's something to be said for that
but you also have to remember that there
was some pretty damn charismatic serial
killers in the past true ya know yeah I
mean you know they weren't all fuck-ups
I mean what's his name
damn Ted Bundy was you know persuasive
yeah hmm that's what I said it's like so
inconclusive yeah I'm not coming down on
one side of the other because I mean
according to pigeon the guy he was
staying with he said that they searched
his house one time and didn't find
anything and then they came back and
searched again and suddenly they found
all this stuff that seemed like
incriminating and he's saying that they
planted it that the cops planted it
there to make Jean Lee were cops planted
stuff though well yeah to make him look
guilty now I'm not saying because I mean
Hart had been convicted in the past of
rape and attempted murder so you know
that there comes a point where it's like
you know how much of it could be
railroaded how much of it is you know
what I'm saying just cuz the guy tries
to kill somebody else and rape some
woman doesn't necessary mean he's gonna
go after a bunch of little girls in the
damn State true it's a different kind of
[ __ ] but it doesn't mean he didn't
conclusive and like I said I should note
that he's pretty much the only the prime
suspect I mean they've never found
anyone else that way that doesn't mean
much either no I know I'm just saying
I'm like I said I'm not coming down one
one way or the other cuz I don't know I
wasn't there there has to be conclusive
proof there's yeah but it but you know
after the [ __ ] they found in pidgins
house and the [ __ ] they found in the
cave he was actually arrested and placed
on trial in spring of 1979 as I said
there
in the community there was a like a
large feeling that he was probably
innocent and it got so bad that when the
little girl's parents like came into
court they apparently needed like
protective escorts because the community
was so dead-set but they thought that
Hart was being railroaded and so they
were taking it out on these poor little
girls these little murdered girls
parents which is kind of shitty too I
mean even if the guy was innocent that's
still shitty it's not their fault so
yeah now some of the evidence they
presented at the trial which seemed to
you know point away from Jean Leroy Hart
okay they said so they found the bloody
footprint in the tent
but Hart apparently wore a size 11 shoe
and the footprints found in the tent
were much smaller than that only about
eight or nine something like that so too
small to be his feet they also said that
the fingerprint that was left on the
lens at the flashlight that they found
at this site was not Hart's fingerprint
also said that they had taken some you
know kind of swabs like you know they
couldn't really do DNA back then but you
know blood typing all that type of stuff
they said that was kind of inconclusive
could have Martin could have matched
Hart but could have maybe not could have
been somebody else that footprint that
footprint is or you know that shoe print
yeah that's important I don't think it
was that dude well now some have
speculated that it might be more than
one person and that he might have been
one of the people what the chances of
getting two people to agree to go out
well on the other hand though it would
be much easier for two guys to control
three little girls because keep in mind
they attacked them in the tent and then
carried them quite a long way down the
path which you don't which is like oh
we'll be easier if you don't you don't
know what he told those little girls I'm
sure he'll I'm sure there's some pretty
strong language from an intimidating
person could [ __ ] control
three girl little girls yeah I got a
feeling that I don't know it's got a
feeling that this might have been
[ __ ] an older teenager that did this
that's just well that's just my and it's
something that they never would have
suspected and it's probably his only
crime that's what I'm thinking it could
be yeah it was but as I he was a
relative of one of the [ __ ]
counselors who knew that it was gonna go
on that's it you know I'm just surmising
yeah so I wouldn't know but it sounds
like it is something kind of like a son
or a cousin or a brother of one of the
counselors knew that all this [ __ ] was
gonna go on new security wasn't that
good well it would seem to be that
somebody I mean I don't know if the note
that was found in the donut box two
weeks before this I mean it would seem
to be related because it specifically
made a threat against three girls on
four girls at the camp and whoever it
was probably knew the layout of the camp
because they knew to target tent number
eight which was the only one that the
counselors couldn't see from their tent
well this is a high profile crime so I'm
sure there's a lot of people runner you
know there might have been kids running
around trying to add evidence to this
you know I mean oh I'm the killer I was
here yeah I mean okay so the hair you
get DNA yeah I mean they match the hairs
that they found there was long black
hair which actually did look like hearts
hair but you know that doesn't
necessarily mean it was his hair I mean
they said over the Native American man
but the shoe print was smaller than his
I just it's somebody who they don't
didn't suspect that's what I'm saying
maybe not yeah I don't know but in any
case if heart did it or not I mean he
was actually acquitted although they
said you know the jury only deliberated
for six hours they came back and said
there was insufficient evidence they
didn't think he had done it so there the
posse
remains that one he didn't do it to that
he did do it but he had an accomplice
who had smaller feet than him you know
other things just find that unlikely
although I have to say that even if he
did do it he didn't get away with it
because you have to remember that he had
escaped from jail for other charges yeah
prior to this so after they had him in
custody even though he was acquitted of
the Oklahoma girl-scout murders he was
actually taken back to prison for that
all the other [ __ ] he did and he had
like a 300-year sentence or something
like that because of all the other [ __ ]
he did so they put him back in jail well
he would have been a likely suspect
because you know he was a bad dude but
yeah I just don't think he did this one
maybe not it's almost it looks like it
looks like to me that the cops were
trying to wash their hands of this they
said what must been this guy yeah well I
mean but that is happening it could have
been him but he might have just been a
division scapegoat because he was kind
of a [ __ ] right and who had done similar
evidence didn't match the fingerprint
and the footprint and I just and that
doesn't sound like his MO yeah maybe not
but you know who knows that's what I
mean knows he did he had like rapes and
pregnant chicks before so and done some
other [ __ ] like that but as I said the
kind of guys that rape adult women tend
not to be after little kids though you
know that's just it does yeah I'm like
I'm not denying that there is some there
can't be some crossover but yeah I mean
generally some but in gym generally
you're either a rapist of adult women or
you're right exactly yeah it's usually
two different psychological profile
exactly it's not usually the same kind
of guy there is some crossover but it's
not really that common yeah um I think
it's unlikely that it was him and that's
why he was acquitted of it yeah well
they just thought there wasn't enough
evidence and there was too much it was
maybe pointing towards someone else like
I said whether by the evidence yeah like
whether it was him and another guy and
like that was the other guys
you know physical evidence nobody knows
I'm gonna see that there's a very good
chance that there's another person out
there that they never suspected to do
this isn't it yeah that's like you know
kind of scary
yeah and I'm thinking that it was
probably swimming there late teens
that's just what I'm thinking yeah it
could be and now he was a he was a young
pedophile type serial killer
yeah and for some reason he did this and
he got it out of his system and was
never captured again because he or he
went somewhere else or he went somewhere
else linked back to a lot of times you
know the cases you know how they are
we've researched a lot of these games
once the guys caught he starts spilling
his guts since yeah I killed those girls
in there because you know they they want
the fame but could have been that he
offended somewhere else and was never
captured I kind of feel like
particularly in the 70s I feel like that
happened a lot because we're so
organized there were so well yeah there
were so they didn't have computers and
we're like so many like I've written
about a lot of cases where you know
something happened and say like
Tennessee and then like a couple months
later something happened in you know
Pennsylvania or something like that and
they didn't really link them until later
like many years later somebody was like
researching the cases like hey these
sound kind of similar maybe that was the
same guy you know but they can't really
prove it at that point because it was
the 1970s and all the evidence has been
degraded or whatever I'm hiccup in like
crazy yeah I see that so um yeah so as I
said Hart still had like three hundred
and five years left on his sentence from
all the other bad [ __ ] that he did so
even though he was acquitted of the
Oklahoma girl-scout murders he was still
taken back to prison to serve the rest
of a sentence for the other charges and
two months after he was taken back to
jail he died of a heart attack
he was only 35 years old five serious
cocaine or you know some some people get
a lucky or you know defect or he was
under a lot of stress I don't really
know but yeah he died at 35 in jail so
he didn't even like serve any of that
sentence right so all right so after
that happened like a lot of the families
of the
girls like trying to sue various people
they tried to sue the owners of the camp
like saying that it was negligent
because you couldn't see the tent and
stuff like that although they ended up
losing um they've also tried to they're
trying to do some DNA on this case and
finally get it solved they really
haven't been able to get anything out of
it though it's like I feel like in in
2017 they were able to raise about
thirty thousand dollars and they were
gonna do like all this do it DNA testing
but I don't know if anything has ever
actually come of that but they do want
to solve this case because what the [ __ ]
somebody just walks into a Girl Scout
camp
we're entails three girls three little
girls out of a tent and just like rapes
and kills them either in the tent or
takes or carries them out of the tent in
their [ __ ] sleeping bags yeah
like I said two of them were raped one
braked and sodomized as far as I
remember like that's what most of the
sources said and what the [ __ ] and they
just like left them like by the path
that was going to the showers and other
than heart
there have been no suspects in this case
so they have no idea who might have done
this no idea whatsoever and like I said
they raise some money they're gonna do
DNA testing but I don't know if anything
has come up that if they've got a
profile because like I said it was a
long time ago and the DNA might have
been degraded at this point but it is so
far never been solved still officially
an unsolved murder that was bizarre
you could do some [ __ ] like that back in
the cities and get away with it that's
[ __ ] horrifying I just I just feel
like like I said man [ __ ] 60 and 70s
not to get old days yeah well even the
[ __ ] evil when people talk about the
good old days like back in the [ __ ]
floor it wasn't a good video there's
never been a good old days it was it's
always sorrow is that it's always bad in
fact if anything it's better than better
yeah these crybabies today talking about
how hard it is now [ __ ] no it was
terrible it was bad back in the eighties
internet had internet and computers have
changed everything
yeah just saw the change happened well I
told you as much as like I like some
things
the 80s I wouldn't go back [ __ ] no no no
[ __ ] now there were certain things that
were good about it yeah there are
certain things that's good about every
air I had to do with the culture and the
movies and [ __ ] certain things yeah that
was fun but everything else it was like
what do you think about it now it's like
everything that's a hard like compared
now
yeah it's like everything's so easy
right it's just finding cool clothes
[ __ ] buddy go think about [ __ ]
finding out information [ __ ] net you
know what I mean we were actually kind
of dumb in a lot of ways yeah not dumb
in terms in terms of like a lack of
intelligence it was a lack of
information yeah
you couldn't find things out yeah you
know just no internet that's changed a
lot so so much easier now so Jesus I
would never go back it's under saying
all young people out there yeah I was I
never like romanticize like there was a
lot of cool [ __ ] about the 80s I love
the music yeah movies I love all that
[ __ ] but I wouldn't go back and live
there now I listen these young
whippersnappers on what they call the
social media Brian I'm crying about [ __ ]
man those [ __ ] are [ __ ] soft as
[ __ ] they don't know what it was like
back then they got it made well and in
the 80s and 70s dandies we were soft
compared to [ __ ] yeah before they
even had a lecture because you're gonna
like old people though man we didn't
have electricity I didn't even walk 14
miles going exactly just like my grandma
used to say yeah so what 40 miles is
gold but barefoot in the snow yeah yeah
any weren't really lying a lot of them
were liked it a lot of them did yeah
yeah they did have it they did a lot of
rough ER so like I said I tried yeah the
wife was very slow back then compared to
now how'd you get anything done how do
you understand it yeah yeah yeah you
gonna be all right I'm gonna be all
right are you gonna drink all right well
we're gonna take a break right now
how long have been doing this for I
don't know okay what's the time an hour
in seven minutes
damn this could be a long show that's
all right people love that Jenny love
those long to our shows yeah okay well
we went off on a lot of dick wall you
would often oh that's our richest
outcome yeah we I knew we were gonna go
off on a digression about Girl Scout
cookies I don't feel like I'm gonna
we're still thinking about the things I
know go ahead for a long time we had
some thin mints frozen in the [ __ ]
freezer and I totally forgot about them
which is crazy but then I found them
like a once again I'm like oh I mean
this whole sleeve
alright so we're gonna take a break
right now and when we come back we will
talk about yet another this was actually
an earlier murder of a girl scout this
happened in Tennessee rather than
Oklahoma this was the murder of Marcia
Trimble so we were gonna talk about that
when we come back we would back in just
a minute
the faceless villain a collection of the
eeriest unsolved murders of the 20th
century volume 2 includes cases spanning
the years from 1960 through 1979
featuring such infamous crimes as the
triple homicide at Lake Bodom the family
massacre known as the good heart murders
the serial killings of the Zodiac Bible
John Jack the stripper and the freeway
phantom the slaughter of dozens of women
and girls along the highway of tears and
the Texas killing fields and the
mysterious death of suspected spy the is
doll woman along with dozens of other
fascinating and horrifying accounts by
it now from Amazon in print Kindle or
audiobook format I may be cookies what
are you doing yeah oh my goodness what a
cutie pie you are you are so cute look
at your little face she's like what I
guess so yeah is that what you're doing
maybe
she's like I was not relaxed and she
[Laughter]
gets you get you yeah all right
that's cool cookies on the show yeah
it's part two
yeah she wanted to come in and see what
we were doing in here thank you
Hey look at that little face sorry you
just listened to the audio version you
can't see her adorable little kitty yeah
cuz she is like looking right in the
camera there little baby there she's
like okay okay yeah alright so part two
of the show we are going to be talking
about yet another murder of a Girl Scout
this actually happened in Tennessee in
1975 this is the case of Marcia Trimble
Marcia Trimble was ten years old nine
years old rather so she lives in this
place called green hills and it was like
it's like kind of an affluent suburb or
it was at the time of Nashville
Tennessee
now green hills Green Hill it was a
neighborhood Janis live in Tennessee and
101st and in Clarksville you know I
don't remember this neighborhood yeah
it's a it's a part of Nashville
Nashville okay I used to like money go
down there my dad's people are from
Tennessee
Springfield actually um okay so this
happens late February 1975 now it's
about 5:00 in the afternoon and Marsha
is at home she has a mom her mom's a
kindergarten teacher and her dad is also
home he she also has a brother named
Chuck and he is out in the driveway
playing basketball with their neighbor
his name is March now their mom Virginia
is making dinner
um and Marsha says I'm gonna go across
the street because she had got her Girl
Scout cookies shipment in that day and
some of the neighbors had ordered
cookies from new Girl Scouts so yeah
well I told you can't talk about Girl
Scout cookies you know what I mean we
know about that yeah so she had just got
her shipment of Girl Scout cashews so
she was gonna go deliver them so she
said well I'm gonna just go across the
street for a second and um you know give
our neighbor the cookies that she
ordered so their neighbors name is Marie
Maxwell so at some time between 5:15 and
5:25 Marsha goes out the back door and
she's seen in the driveway she's just
like a little bitty girl she has a
cardboard box in her hand that had all
her Girl Scout cookie boxes in it she
had about twenty dollars in an envelope
that was money that she had from people
that had bought Girl Scout cookies so
she goes um Marie Maxwell whose house
she was going to live right across the
street so Marcia's going over to deliver
the cookies now Marie Maxwell had just
come home from the grocery store so she
pulls into the driveway now she starts
taking groceries out of the car now she
sees through the bushes like on the side
of her house presumably she says that
she sees Marsha and that she was in the
driveway of the neighboring house and
she was talking to two people one bigger
than her and one smaller than her now
consider that Marsha was only nine years
old and she was only about four foot ten
so this is gonna be like a little kid
and maybe a slightly older kids that she
was talking to now she thought that the
smaller kid was probably their neighbor
and a friend of hers whose name was
March he was about ten years old um
now the taller kids she wasn't really
sure who it is but she thought it might
have been one of their other neighbors
whose name was Jeffrey Womack which will
you know come into play later on Womack
yeah that's my grandmother's name in the
south it's interesting maybe they're
related Katharine Womack yeah
okay so now at this point um Marie she
sees she's like I only saw the little
girl like she only saw Marshall in the
back but she's like I saw kind of the
side of her face and I recognized it was
her so she's like so I went inside the
house and I wrote her a check
for the cookies because I figured that
she was coming over to deliver the
cookies because she saw the cookie box
in her hand so she goes out inside to
write it write a check but then Marcia
never comes over now at this point
they're not really sure where the little
girl went about a half hour later
somebody said that they saw a girl that
might have been her and they saw her at
the corner of these two streets called s
T's and Hobbs this was about 3/10 of a
mile from where she was last seen which
was like her neighbor I think it was
like a it was the house across from her
but one over um so this was about 3/10
of a mile from there like somebody's are
there but she didn't have the box full
of cookies now another witness also saw
her about five minutes after that this
was about 5:35 p.m. and saw her farther
out the street she was walking down the
street on Hobbs Street and she was
walking toward like a tree nursery that
was down there now this person also said
that she didn't have her cookie box with
her and that she looked kind of confused
so at this point like later speculation
was that maybe someone had taken her
cookie box like it had stolen it and
that she was like she's like maybe a kid
took it like as a joke and so she was
like chasing after them but they're not
really sure now at this stage between
about 5:30 and 6:00 Jeffery Rome Womack
who is the person that who's kind of a
neighbor of theirs who the neighbor said
that she saw Marcia maybe talking to him
but she wasn't sure if it was him or not
now he comes into the house of a woman
named Peggy Morgan and that was his
next-door neighbor
Peggy Morgan ran a daycare center like
it out of her house and Jeffrey Womack
like I said this this guy will be
important later on
um he often came over he was only 15 at
the time he often came over to kind of
help her babysit the kids and stuff so
he comes over Peggy says that he's kind
of like sweaty looking he looks like
he's been running around or he's all
sweaty he says he's just been playing
basketball so no one thinks any more
about that now at this stage back at the
Trimble house they have been started to
become concerned that Marsha has not
come home yet because she said she was
just popping over to the neighbor's
house across the street to deliver the
cookies and get the money for the
cookies that the group that the woman
had ordered so her mom Virginia light
goes out and starts calling for her and
she's not there so um so they start so
they actually called the cops and the
cop says well why don't you like before
you like report her missing like you
know officially or anything let's drive
around the neighborhood and we'll look
for so they start looking around the
neighborhood start driving around but
they don't find her so then um you know
all the cops start kind of converging at
the house now keep in mind that this is
a pretty affluent neighborhood this is
not something that happens there a lot
and even initially the cops were not
alarmed I mean they thought well maybe
she just wandered off and she lost track
of time or you know she's just running
away cuz she had a fight with her
parents or something like no one is
thinking that she's been kidnapped and
murdered at this stage this is not
something that happened in this
neighborhood in 1975 so they weren't
even really thinking about that or they
think maybe she's been in an accident
maybe she's been hit by a car or
something of that nature so no one was
thinking anything really terrible at
this stage so they call all the cops out
they get the helicopters they get the
dogs they get everything like that
now um yeah so so then meet back up ok
let's run through this this run to this
again she was seen talking to somebody a
taller person and a shorter person she
had her box of cookies with yes and then
later on she seen some seen by somebody
else she doesn't have the bus was seen
by two other separate people did and she
doesn't have the box of cookies
and she looks confused yeah that's weird
so that mean that's telling me some
somehow she lost that box of cookies
yeah after talking to those people yeah
what do you make of that Jay I'm not
really sure about that because in light
of what they find out of what they found
out later I'm not really sure what the
timeline of the situation is because all
right and I'm gonna get a little spoiler
alert here because for a lot of for many
years it was speculated that Marcia had
been kidnapped and killed by someone she
knew like a teenager that lived in the
neighborhood perhaps Jeffrey Womack
um they that they had taken her cookies
or they have like lured her somewhere
and like did horrible things to her but
as it turned out later that probably
wasn't the case so these sightings of
her like first she's seen talking to her
two friends in the neighboring driveway
and she had her cookies but then later
two other witnesses said yeah we saw her
walking down the street she didn't have
her cookies so I'm not really sure like
what happened like in the interim it's
it's really hard for me to like imagine
a scenario you have oh I don't know
well they said she just sold her cookies
well they said it was it she had a
cardboard box and I'm just like I don't
know I used to be in the Girl Scouts
though yeah and like when you you know
went around and you sold your cookies to
you know your mom's friends at work or
whatever and then they would send you
the shipment and all your cookies were
like in a big cardboard box like from
Amazon or something and then you would
take those and you would like distribute
them to like the people that had bought
them from your little list or whatever
so I'm assuming that that's what it was
I'm assuming that it was like a large
cardboard box with a bunch of boxes of
because she was going to deliver cookies
that's what she was doing when she was
getting she was gathering money so could
it have been that her cookies weren't
taken but she sold them all uh so he
bought him like I'll buy them all I'm
not really sure because like I said
normally what you would do like I said I
used to be in Girl Scouts I don't know
if it you know and I'm assuming
this was a little bit before my time
this was 1975 I was in the Girl Scouts
probably the late 70s or early 80s but
it was the same kind of thing you just
you didn't get any cookies at first okay
you just got the list and you went
around and everybody's like who wants
cookies and then you wrote their names
reordered because and then you
pre-ordered them okay either they gave
you money or they said I'll give you
money when the cookies come you know
it's C OD or whatever and then you know
so she what she was doing was she was
she had some money and she was
delivering the cookies to the people
that already paid her yeah and then she
had cookies that people said they were
gonna pay her for later and she was
gonna deliver them let me okay how much
of those cookies what then ornate oh
yeah now how much are they now when was
the last time we bought a box that we
had some cookies they're few maybe five
fifty maybe 650 for one box I think so
they're not cheap no they're not cheap
well but like I said it's you know it's
it's to raise money for Girl Scouts
right I don't mind paying a little bit
more and this damn coconut cookies what
they call Kunis mccune is which calls
Samoans Samoans yes samoan Samoas
they're the hawaiian cookies yeah yeah
like from the island of Samoa if you're
not if you're not Nina it states the
Girl Scouts a particular time of year
it's usually it's usually like late
winter or spring and they they're in the
malls they're in front of grocery stores
in front of like Home Depot they set up
a little table with other little moms
and whatnot if you're not an American
you're not around these good these
cookies are badass I'm not sure what it
is about them they're like very good
the Samoas are [ __ ] thick - they're
like um from when I remember a half inch
thick
yeah they're tall thick cookies love man
yeah I know now you're making big condom
they're kind of like we're kind of like
something you get from Keebler yeah but
they're just they're just better I don't
know why well cuz you paid a lot more
for it I guess and Nick in the peanut
butter chocolate covered
vanna I can't remember what those are
they don't have like cute little names
what I do what their their route yeah a
little bubble of peanut butter right I'm
like I said I used to be in girls games
and they cover the whole [ __ ] what it's
like a chocolate yeah they're really
good girl scouts know what they're doing
the Girl Scouts gonna make them so they
sub them out but okay so there's no way
of really knowing what happened those
cookies are what happened that girl
before she disappeared yeah now they're
saying right yeah well they know what
happened to a few of the cookies but I'm
not gonna okay yeah all right so uh what
cuz that's a clue if you could find out
what happened
coquí's then you know one thing I will
note is that this is kind of an
interesting detail was that at this
point you know they they assumed that
the child has gone missing or been
abducted or has had something happened
to her so they had a reporter from a
local news agency like come to talk to
the family about the case that reporter
was Oprah Winfrey this was actually
before she got really famous Oprah was
on this case yes this was before she was
famous she was still working for a local
channel in Tennessee yeah and she
actually came to the house like to
interview the parents but they told her
that they were too upset and they didn't
want to talk to her so they told her to
go away and she did so there was that
whole thing um okay so now the cops come
the the cops have started interviewing
like some of the kids in the
neighborhood about where Marsha might
have gone now according to him some of
them said well oh don't worry about her
she's with Jeffrey Jeffrey Womack
Jeffrey Womack apparently had also even
though he's only 15 he had actually
bought some cookies from her too and he
had said later that he was like oh well
she was gonna bring me the cookies but I
didn't have the money so I had to go
back to my house and all this other kind
of stuff so some of the neighborhood
kids said that she was with Jeffrey and
not to worry about her so after the kids
said
the cops were like well maybe we should
go check out this Jeffrey Womack kid so
they all go to his house but he's not
home now around 9:00 9:30 in the evening
Jeffery apparently finds out that the
cops are looking for him so they act so
he actually goes to the Trimble house
where all the cops have kind of set up a
little impromptu you know kind of
investigation room or whatever he
composed they set it up there so he
actually goes to the house and he says
well I was out looking for her because I
heard that she was missing so I was at
this quarry and so they start asking him
about what had happened now at the time
they didn't really consider him a
suspect now they did ask him to turn out
his pockets um what was in his pockets
which doesn't seem all that suspicious
they found five dollars they've got a
roll of pennies they also got an unused
condom which they thought later was like
oh well maybe that had something to do
with something but you know he was 15
it's like you know he has a [ __ ] car
do you do that's what I mean not carried
a [ __ ] around so it fell apart yeah yeah
they're almost certain the dam breaks
right round eleventh grade you know I
mean and then it's just full spectrum
you know thought about you can't stop it
full spectrum it's like full spectrum I
thought you you said it not me I'm not
even gonna speculate coming from every
direction what you might mean by that
full spectrum is just too much of it
yeah yeah all right so that's how it was
for me when I was at Brazil at that time
I'll say you're a boy I'm a boy yeah I
was a boy back then it was different it
was [ __ ] hilarious yeah well that's
what I mean it's like I kind of feel
like and you know I write about a lot of
these true crime cases and some of the
[ __ ] that
say it's like they're like well the
first thing that made us suspect this
person was XY and Z but you have to
think of it as like if no one had gotten
murdered would anybody think X Y & Z was
weird so I'm thinking a 15 year old boy
with an unused condom in his pocket if
no one got murdered would anyone think
that was weird no that's what I mean no
one would think that was weird
they're only thinking that and also they
were like oh well on his sneakers he had
written like [ __ ] you like on the toes
and I'm like big deal I did that too I
did that too when I was a teen I really
strive to go to stuff that's that's
really not that weird all in ink pan
while the second board any class yeah
yeah I was old like two other cops think
of it like it like if no one had got
murdered when anyone think this was
weird because I think some things only
seem weird because someone got murdered
but like if no one got murdered no one
would think that was weird
no you know what I mean so I maybe feel
like that's what happened in this kid's
case but I'm not entirely sure so
Jeffrey Womack is getting interviewed by
the cops at the Trimble house now then
Peggy Morgan who was a neighbor of
Jeffrey Womack she was the one
remembered that owned the daycare that
Jeffrey Womack sometimes it worked at
now she was um older than him she was
like in her 30s she comes into the
Trumbull house and she says to the cops
Jeffrey didn't do anything he was with
me which they thought was a little weird
because you know no one had how would
you yeah yeah it's like no one had
necessarily accused him of anything I
mean you know what I mean so they
thought that was a little strange I'm
[ __ ] I'm related to climb a wall back
back blood in me I can't understand it
if this [ __ ] a writer I'll have
to track him down I honestly don't
I doubt that he I mean seriously
he was a 15 year old kid at this mission
was I I honestly don't think I'll hope
he's good boy I mean I don't know it was
another
but I don't think he had anything to do
it so all right so Peggy Morgan this
older woman comes over and says he
didn't have anything to do with it
so um they later found out though that
Jeffrey hadn't actually been with her he
had actually been at her house because
like I said he helped out with her day
care so he'd been over there watching
the kids while she was out doing
something else she was running errands
or going bowling or whatever it was she
was doing so they hadn't actually been
together but she had but he had been at
her house now at this stage Jeffrey's
parents thought that the cops were being
a little too like overbearing and we're
trying to like get him to admit to
something and they didn't think he'd
done anything so they hired a lawyer for
him which I think maybe made the cops
think that they had something to hide
but the parents said you know well we
were just like protecting our interests
and we didn't think you know our kid did
anything so we decided we would hire a
lawyer just for protection so that was
that whole thing - now they polygraphed
Jeffrey Rome Womack
I believe two times at least and he
passed both times and so he was all
right as well several of the
investigators now like I said there's
still some controversy though like
separately the investigators thought
that he was being truthful they thought
they asked him do did you know anything
about what happened with Marcia Trimble
did you hurt her and he said no and it
looked like he was telling the truth so
you know to make of that what you will
um now it should be noted - that okay so
so they're still searching for this
little girl they pretty much pulled out
all the stops they had all the dogs
helicopters the whole [ __ ] deal and
everything like that they said the cops
one of the cops
I remember this quote it said something
like it you know it was such a carnival
atmosphere he's like you you kept
looking around expecting to see a ferris
wheel because there was just [ __ ]
reporters and [ __ ] like all over the
[ __ ] Trimble's yard
so you know as I said this this whole
search is going on now to make a long
story short it was 33 days before they
found Marcia Trimble's body now where
they found her was in it was like kind
of a dilapidated shed it was like made
of wood and have like windows but it's
having a glass in them it was only about
a hundred and fifty two hundred yards
from her parents house now [ __ ] [ __ ]
didn't they check that well here's the
thing there are some controversy about
that too because there's a contingent of
cops that insist that they searched that
shed during this which they probably
would have because yeah that's pretty
damn it was a massive search going on
and that they didn't find her body at
the time as issues but thereafter but
forensic evidence would seem to suggest
that she had been there the whole time
so there's kind of like you know so
could the Picasa blown it off and why
perhaps that's what I mean I'm you know
I'm not really sure how that's gonna go
but yeah so how she was found was this
happened it was March 30th of 1975 1976
whatever it was it was 33 days yeah so
it was 1975 so there's this guy named
Harry Moffitt and he is looking through
this shed he was looking for a cover for
his boat engine now the house where the
shed was attached to it wasn't his but
it belonged to his relatives who were
the Thorpes so he's looking for the boat
engine thing and he goes in this shed
and he sees these legs like sticking out
from under a bunch of like this pile of
rubble or whatever now at first he
thought it was a doll but he started
poking it with a stick and then he
thought maybe it was really a body so he
called the police now like I said when
the police got there some of them were
like hey we checked this [ __ ] there was
no body in here back then and you know
so there was a whole controversy about
that this was um actually I should note
that it
Easter Sunday of that year when the body
was found
now there's there's a chance that that
could be right
could be somebody had cus it's my
holding there they were searching for
they searched that place she wasn't in
there but then later he went back and
put her in there and kill her yeah you
know there's a possibility there was
here there's the search was [ __ ]
half-ass and they didn't see the [ __ ]
I'm kind of leaning more toward that
because okay the forensic evidence okay
for one thing they said they found dirt
on her shoes but all the dirt was on the
soles which would lead them to believe
that she had walked into the garage
rather than being dragged into the
grouch because if she had been dragged
the dirt would be on the back of the
shoes or on the front of the shoes and
not on the bottom of the shoe so it
looked like she had walked in there
voluntarily also maybe under duress well
that too but that she was still alive
when she went in there um also they said
that because of you know how they do the
aunt Molly the the insects
you know the insect generations or
whatever OCD yes they said that
fragments
yeah from the insect you know activity
on the body it looked as though the body
had been in there for the entire 33 days
meaning that she had been killed shortly
after she had disappeared
and that she had man in the garage the
whole time but a one or two day yeah
true
leeway point there you know we'll see
true but like I said I'm not sure when
because like I said it was a lot it was
more than a month between the time she
disappeared and between the time they
found her body so they had done several
searches of the area and this shed like
I said was only 150 200 yards from her
house yeah said that they could that
they had searched it before and that
there was nothing in there 200 yards man
that's less than a rifle shot I mean
that's clash that is very close it was
like a neighbor's house yeah
and it was like a shed behind the
neighbor's house the Thorian were like
their neighbors
it was either like behind their house or
wood like it was a down a block like
that that's what I mean so it seemed
strange that they had searched the area
so if there
but hadn't found it and then later on it
was found so there like I said there's
still some controversy about whether
that ideal then maybe the cops looking
popped ahead in there one hey you in
here and then now she's not here and
then she's not walked out well I you
know I I feel like here's the thing
whatever humans are involved there's
error there's gonna be error yeah when
you have forensics bugs you know dirt
yeah you know any kind of forensic
evidence I'm gonna take that over a
person's word any day he was in there
when I checked they didn't see it yeah
maybe they didn't because she was
underneath a bunch of [ __ ] yeah they
were half-assing yeah they didn't the
cops didn't think she would be in there
cuz that was too close maybe even Zama
hey you and Erin she's not in here
strong yeah cuz I feel like a lot of
times and you know don't no disrespect
to cops but they were busy I think a lot
of times yeah they're busy that's like
they have a lot of a large area to
search they're not gonna like [ __ ] go
through everything with a fine-tooth
comb they're just gonna pop their head
in somewhere and be like well I don't
see her in there I got a feeling they
were already under the [ __ ] they were
already under the assumption that she
was taken somewhere they didn't expect
her to be so close yeah so when they
walked in there
they just called looked around real
quick to see okay because this wasn't
like a house it was just it was a shed
and it was kind of a dilapidated old
shed it was like an old wooden you know
like a boat shed type of thing didn't
even have like any windows like the
inner glass she was in the Aesir
yeah even the guy that went in there
looking for [ __ ] all he saw was legs he
saw little legs sticking out and he
thought it was a doll they didn't want
it they didn't want to admit they
searched it thoroughly I'm I'm kind of
leaning toward that like I don't know
but I'm leaning toward that because I
like I said I'll go with the forensic
evidence and any day the week over over
person's word like everybody's will just
saying we certain that we didn't see
anything for you first time listeners
I'm ex-military and I [ __ ] devil law
enforcement [ __ ] words for Louisiana
State Police for a while
just because they're cops doesn't mean
they don't [ __ ] up
well it's a job anything uh Peter how
fast their jobs all the time I'm not
[ __ ] anybody everybody doesn't you
have to understand that your average cop
really on the force for a couple of
years before he gets fired or he quits
so just because the guy's a cop doesn't
necessarily mean he's really good at
what he's doing or he really gives a
[ __ ] you know there's a certain kind of
person that makes it as a cop and then
your average guy just doesn't you know
that it's the same thing with the
military yeah so chances are it was just
some guys that went in there you know I
mean and there was like oh you know
she's not around here whoever got her
took her far away yeah that was that was
what they were thinking and they walked
in there and called and looked around
didn't see anything
they're like that [ __ ] in there and
they [ __ ] walked out then later she's
oh no we checked
we checked Sarge that's kind of you're
not feeling we check lead to see it no
no no no she wasn't in there Sarge you
know that [ __ ] they were saying yeah
they wanted to cover their yeah yeah
yeah because they don't want to say you
know [ __ ] no we didn't think she you
know I mean that's all for clothes yeah
yeah that's kind of what I'm feels right
like I said I wasn't there but right I
want to feel like all right so what they
discovered when they found the body they
figured that she had been killed at or
very near the time that she had
disappeared from forensics it looked
very much like she had been in that shed
the whole time she was gone also they
determined that the killer had stolen
the $20 that she had that she had
collected for her cookies they also
thought that probably she had been
strangled her hyoid bone was not crushed
but it was broken you know which is
usually an indication of strangulation
also she had been sexually assaulted
although they didn't tell her parents
this for a long time until like much
later in the proceedings and they were
kind of upset about it as you might
understand now because they thought that
15 year-old Jeffrey Womack was kind of
the main suspect in the case he lived
around there you know he said that he
was looking for you know there was
like the weird thing about the neighbor
and trying to cover for him and [ __ ]
like that so what they decided to do was
that there was one of the homicide
detectives whose name was detective
McElroy he decided that well I guess he
didn't decide but they you know the the
police officers decided that they were
going to let him go undercover and see
if he could figure find out anything
about this Jeffrey Womack kid now at
this stage a few years had passed since
the murder because they couldn't really
you know pin it on anyone in particular
so what this what McElroy did was he
went undercover as an ex-con from
Alabama and he went to work at the same
restaurant that Jeffrey Womack worked at
now what Mack was still in a teenager at
this time I think he was only 17 or 18
years old so McElroy kind of like goes
to work at this restaurant as a cook and
like tries to at like hang out with them
and like tries to go out with them but
other times try to get him to like admit
something now as far as I know he never
did admit anything outright some of his
friends at school later said that he
would make jokes about you know if they
razzed him about the crime because
everyone at school like all his friends
knew that he was a suspect or a person
of interest so a lot of them would kind
of razz him about it so he'd be like
yeah I killed her yeah I did this done
the other but they all kind of thought
that he was joking just to like get them
to shut up you know what I mean other
than that the cops couldn't really get
anything on him um even though they kind
of followed him around for a long time
so you know there was that whole thing
but one thing that made them kind of you
know that made them kind of interested
him in him as a suspect was that what
they did was that when McElroy was
undercover like working at this
restaurant he got one of the other
detectives to come into the restaurant
and come up to the bar and asked
about like kind of asked him about the
detective because he was pretending that
he didn't know who the detective was and
he said that Jeffrey Womack said to him
he's like oh I know who that guy is
you know the detective he's been
investigating me for the little girl
that was murdered with a tarp covered
over her now the fact that he said the
word terror he saw the question
interesting because in the press yeah it
had been reported that she was covered
with like a um like one of those blow up
swimming pools yeah that that was one of
the thing that was one of the things
that was over her now the thing that was
found over her body was actually not a
tarp it was actually a shower curtain
but when they found it it did kind of
look like a tarp hmm so they thought
that it was kind of interesting that he
used that word instead of saying
swimming pool or whatever like most of
the press had been reporting that it had
been a swimming pool so that was one
thing that made them like hmm maybe he
does know something about this that's
why they kept investigating go there is
there is room for error
oh sure [ __ ] think of a swimming pool
cover it's kind of a dark ya understand
there is a little bit of there's a
little bit of leeway there yeah and like
I said you know in light of later events
I'm not sure how you know but I'm just
kind of going along alright as it is
because they're mean there had been
other things like where her body was in
the shed there was a bunch of [ __ ] like
over her body now as far as they could
remember the only thing that had been
reported was that there was like like a
deflated I don't know if it was deflated
but it was kind of like one of those
blowup swimming pools was like over her
body whether one of some of the press
might have mentioned a tarp or shower
curtain I don't really know but the fact
that he said tarp kind of made them go
because they were thinking oh everyone
thought it was a swimming pool so why
did he say tarp they thought that was
weird
now they kind of like looked into this
tarp slash shower curtain that they
found that was one of the things that
was over her body and they determined
that this
shower curtain had also been used at
some point as like a drop cloth when
someone was painting now the paint that
was on there matched some of the paint
from that chicks house what Peggy Morgan
I think her name was who was like a
neighbor of Jeffrey Womack so the paint
on the tarp was the same as the paint
from her house now whether that had
anything to do with the murder or not I
don't know because like I said it was
just a shed that was a bunch of [ __ ] in
the shed
it's like somebody could have just
murdered her and stuffed her underneath
this stuff and it didn't have anything
to do with the stuff that was in there
but you know what I mean they're just
like investigating this [ __ ] that had to
do with it so there was that whole thing
- um they also interviewed Peggy Morgan
who as I said was the woman that ran the
daycare that Jeffrey Womack he kind of
worked for and she was kind of like
super protective of him and they said
that she was really uncooperative and
that when they were trying to like ask
her questions about Jeffrey or about the
murder and stuff she was like why don't
you go out and find the real killers and
she was being really damn must have been
involved well yeah maybe well I kind of
suspected like I don't know like I said
I wasn't there sometimes a woman can
slip and fall and fall on the way
they're talking about it it's like she
was in her 30s sure and he was 15 at the
time some weird it did seem to me that
maybe there was something going on
between the two of them yeah she
protests too much because I mean the way
she was she was very protective of him
either because she was sleeping with him
or because she thought of him of him is
like a kid yeah one of those two things
well we're playing around I'm just
saying there's no way no one yeah like I
said I don't know it was a long time ago
right it could be either of this maybe
she just felt like a mother figure to
him and she was like really pretty boy
like you would think of yeah like he
would do toward your son right because
like I said he was helping her out with
the babysitting business he was still
kind of a sexier dick was involved but
you know I mean [ __ ] it could've been
good well it's always sex it could it
could be there I think I think well I
could think
anything wouldn't make a difference it
was too long ago I don't know yeah and
that's what I'm saying and I'm not
really sure like I said because okay now
they determined later and like I said
his her poor parents Marcia Trimble's
parents did not find this out until
later on that she had actually been
raped however her hymen was still intact
it's a little dick mother meaning there
yes that this was an adolescent boy or
it was a man with a very small micro
analysis I mean they did find semen so
he obviously got semen inside of her and
they found some semen on her clothing is
not enough man couldn't even break the
seat that's what I mean that's why they
were thinking that it was actively a
teenage boy although it could have been
a man with with a small penis it could
have been that - mm-hmm I'm just saying
poor [ __ ] and now she was also
when she was found she was dressed which
made some investigators think that maybe
she was sexually assaulted elsewhere
maybe at the nursery that she was seen
walking toward by some of the witnesses
and then later kind of taken back to old
was she again nine because they're
saying that she must have been raped
somewhere how do they actually know she
was raped do you know how they know that
because they found semen in her okay all
right so yeah she was yeah yeah it's
just her hymen wasn't broken that's what
I mean that's why they think that it was
a kid or a boy or a man with a small
penis because he did a kid busted not
though no but teenage boy can show yeah
but usually by the time you can do that
then you're already big well it depends
on the person
yeah it's like I said right because they
were saying I mean the car is from
personal experience I mean you know
[ __ ] gonna get huge rounds
around that time I mean he must have
been if that was a teenage boy he must
have been in a weird what they call a
awkward phase you know talk about yeah
to where
you could you could deliver a load of
semen okay I'm being being political
okay but you're not big that's [ __ ]
weird it's because we're really well by
the time to tell you what I don't want
to give up any personal information but
by the time those hormones kick in for
your average guy you know talking about
your [ __ ] big by the time you could
do that yeah
but not everyone is okay that's a weird
[ __ ] right there no I'm just
saying well like I said that's why they
thought that it was like yeah some micro
dick [ __ ] or it was a little it
was a teenager or someone you know those
hormones kick in you're talking about
yeah I can remember it was like
overnight [ __ ] is that that's usually
how it goes yeah it's probably the same
thing of women in [ __ ] boobs
um not one down one day you might be
caught you don't have boobs next day you
get [ __ ] big-ass boobs I don't
remember it being like that okay
although I remember being the first
thing I remember is being in fifth grade
I remember that I remember the first day
of school in fifth grade and I had um
let's say grown substantially over the
summer yeah and I had to get a bra I
couldn't just get one of those training
bras like NRT they're got It's Me
Margaret I had to get like a real bra
yeah it was only like a bull hose right
even though it was only 9 or 10 years
old and I remember going to school the
first day with the bra things right and
I was uncomfortable yeah and I I was
wearing this like white carriage shirt
no I was wearing like a white shirt and
it had like a like those 3/4 sleeves
that were navy blue and had a unicorn on
there someone was in fifth grade come on
it was the 80s and I remember the very
first day a boy snapped the back of my
bra yeah
very first day for me because a lot of
5th grade girls were not wearing bras
and also I was in ballet class at the
time and I was the only girl a lot of
the girls were the same age as me or a
little bit younger and I was easily the
most developed of all the girls in that
class so I got a so I had to wear a bra
under my leotard so I got [ __ ] about
that as well no tell me know why you you
can't do that you can't do that for me
it was like like overnight you know that
man yeah I remember it being overnight
it was like overnight I remember it
being like a several months process
because I remember it like overnight
well I remember I remember being in
fourth grade and nothing weird
particularly happening and then over the
summer and then when I started in fifth
grade then all of a sudden the nightmare
began okay for me it was like one day I
was like what I remember it well they
all the way like that guy now is like
[Laughter]
bashing people in second right I was
like as a backup all right it's not good
it's not the same for girls yeah it's
just it was kind of like that like I
said I show up in fifth grade and I had
the biggest boobs at burying the class
so obviously I'm getting teased it's
like dudes are snapping my bra it's like
because they were trying to get the game
it sucked until then it's all following
year so the game when you know the the
thing with the menstruation happened
that was super fun also that was like
early part of seventh grade everything
like yeah alright so in 1979 which if
you're keeping track is about four years
after the murder took place they decide
they're going to put Jeffrey Womack on
trial for the murder but they can't
determine whether they should try him as
a teenager since he was 15 when the
thing occurred or if they should try him
as an adult so that was like a whole
thing about that um so they all right so
as I said they're still kind of like
this is this
age and this is like I said if you keep
in track this is four years later this
is when the parents found out that
Marcia had been raped they didn't know
all this time they only found out at
this hearing where they were trying to
determine the whole [ __ ] wall Mac
respond yeah she put him up for trial
yeah well so yeah there was there was
that whole thing and like he had a
attorney and the Zipit and his defense
attorney kind of brings up which was
probably a pretty salient point he was
like you know there was a lot of like
other weird [ __ ] going on in this
neighborhood there was this guy that
lived in a neighborhood that went around
exposing himself to little kids you know
there was all this other kind of stuff
going on there was this other guy that
had like you know children's clothing
fetish I guess so
he's like there wasn't necessarily um
you know any reason to think that
Jeffrey Womack was responsible just
because he happened to be there at the
time and it really wasn't another a lot
of other like evidence suggesting that
he was guilty you know other than like
the jokes he had made about yeah I
killed her yeah I raped her yet this
just because people kept picking on him
about it because everybody knew that he
was a suspect so you know there was that
whole thing also now I lost my place
so in a few years later they actually
decide they're just gonna drop all the
charges they don't have enough evidence
there's like there's nothing to you know
convict the guys so they pretty much let
him go now it's kind of like a lot of
some of the investigators think that
he's still guilty so they're still kind
of like you know this thing what
evidence though that's what I mean it's
like I feel like as much as I write
about this case I feel like the only
evidence against him is just that he
thought you there yeah and that maybe
Marcia was talking to him before she
disappeared
and maybe for a while they thought that
her rapist was a teenager just because
it's a not hymen breaking thing and like
all that but that's not enough that's
not yeah that is like less than
circumstantial
that's just like really like not even
anything they take a semen sample um
they did but here's the thing
they took DNA samples I mean like I said
this was 1975 so when they looked into
the DNA samples later they were pretty
inconclusive now some investigators have
said that they believe the DNA shows
that there was a there was three or four
different semen samples like different
men like she was gang-raped you know
what I mean but then other investigators
by for little did maybe like it might
have been kids does it make sense
but then some investigators say well the
DNA isn't that mean they know she was
raped by somebody but they don't know if
it was more than one person so there's
there's also controversy there because
the DNA evidence isn't good enough you
know it's kind of degraded because it
was so long ago and they didn't really
preserve it all that well so they're not
really sure if this was one perpetrator
if this was several perpetrators some
investigators have speculated that maybe
she was gang-raped by a bunch of little
kids or a bunch of boys and then they
killed her accidentally because she was
screaming or something like that so
there's a lot of different theory
going around this so what might have
happened to her yeah it really does now
they did like all for a while like in
1990 they actually redid like they they
did the DNA they tried to like go around
they went to pretty much everybody in
the neighborhood that was living there
at the time that was about the age that
they thought the killer might have been
and tried to obtain DNA evidence by
basically like going to people's doors
and saying hey can we have your blood
can we have your hair can we have all
this other kind of stuff and they were
being kind of you know a little bit
overbearing about it and some people had
a problem with that but of all the
samples that they obtained they didn't
find a match so there was that whole
issue now they tested about 70 people at
the time but didn't find a match what
ended up happening was that the the [ __ ]
went pretty much stagnant for many many
years until the early 2000s okay I gotta
stop because I gotta find my [ __ ]
place on it not a lot
this year the 2000 what yeah
so the case pretty much went stagnant
until like the late 2000s now in 2008
they arrests or indicted rather the 60
year old guy named Jerome Sydney Barrett
and he was actually charged in 2008 with
the murder of Marcia Trimble now how he
had come to the attention of authorities
was that there had been kind of a
similar case that happened in 1975 only
a month or two after the murder of
Marcia Trimble there was a girl named
Sarah Despres who was a student at
Vanderbilt and this happened and
actually had before the murder of Marcia
Trimble is about three weeks before she
was also raped and murdered now DNA
evidence pointed to this Barrett guy as
the suspect and her murder and DNA later
proved it and then later on somebody
said hey the mo seems very similar to
how Marcia Trimble was killed so maybe
we should check that out this was later
on and when they did the day in at DNA
testing they found that the DNA on
Marcia Trimble that they had found
matched this guy now this guy he was 60
years old in 2008 so would that I made
him a teenager at the time in 1975 maybe
maybe I can't add at this at this stage
in my I'm too drunk to add yeah that's
what I mean but the thing about it
though was that this guy had not lived
in the neighborhood um he was an
african-american man and this
neighborhood was all white um he had
been working in the neighborhood at the
time I don't know if he was doing like
yard work or he was doing some kind of
construction or it was something like
that at the time and he was like I said
he had done this murder of this
Vanderbilt student which that was only a
few miles away from where Marcia Trimble
was killed that was Sarah to pray also
there was a student at Belmont
University who was not murdered but she
was raped and that was
in March of 1975 way more this is a
black dude who can't break the hymen on
a nine-year-old girl well I don't buy
that like wait how old was he though at
the time because night 2008 he was 60
when he was arrested in 2008
okay the crime happened the crimes that
he was convicted of happened in 1975
second teens are 20 about 20 right yeah
maybe had micro dick why some people
have that that's the thing I think that
brother was packing well yeah but the
reason he might have been going around
raping people was because he but anyway
yeah so apparently this murder has been
solved as far as I know last I look to
like it [ __ ] articles from 2017-2018
they have actually convicted him of the
murder of Marcia Trimble so it does turn
out that it wasn't just some teenager in
the neighborhood that knew her it was
some random dude that was just working
there so they convicted him that perhaps
just saw her yes so as far as I know
unlike the DNA evidence seemed to seems
to you know that it seems to be him so
and he had done some other similar
crimes in the area there were a couple
other rapes and murders in the area like
I think one of the women that was raped
actually lived like right behind the
Trimble family like you know just like
their yard was like adjacent to their
yard so he was kind of like targeting
some people in the neighborhood it
seemed like okay so apparently this one
has been solved and it wasn't who anyone
who they thought it was like once again
it was just a random mother which I
always thought was kind of itchy yeah
it's like you know what I mean it's like
and I'm not gonna [ __ ] on the
investigators because you know 9 times
out of 10 99 times out of 100 you know
when someone is murdered and someone
they knew or someone they had an
association with you know because random
murders are so much harder to solve but
sometimes it is
some random [ __ ] even though it
does maybe seem like it was somebody
that knew them and I and I understand
why they pursue that Avenue first
because that's usually who it is seamos
not always most these homicides are easy
to solve because it's not a random
[ __ ] that's what I mean so you
never hear about that right so 99 times
they would be right so the ones that
aren't salt a lot of times there's a
random [ __ ] that's why it's not
solved yeah right I think that's why and
that might be the case in the Oklahoma
Girl Scout murders too it's like I don't
know if it was that Jean Lee or a Harker
guy or not but it might just be some
random guy that they haven't thought of
because if some just random [ __ ] dude
is passing through the area decides to
kill some people and then takes off you
would never know well that was my
instinct is that the suspect or the guy
who did it was not a suspect there was a
random person it may be all those that
pursued did seem like a douche but other
I mean I think he was a [ __ ] but
other than that I don't really know if
he did that or not it was somebody who
knew about that event yeah or knew about
that camp because like I said it wasn't
an event that happened again the camp
they came every summer right that's what
I met somebody knew about that camp and
that summer event and decided they were
gonna get us up like he said that might
have been some relation of somebody that
had worked there yeah you know that work
there had worked there as a counselor or
something like that some kind of
pedophile heard about yeah might have
been something like that because that
was probably like common knowledge in
the area was a girl scout camp up there
cuz it was a big camp it was like 400
acres you mean you think about unique a
town in that area and everything so
could have been anybody in that town
yeah that would have heard about it
oh yes Girl Scouts what can they meet
there every year I'm gonna get some of
that yeah I'm gonna go up there and yeah
yeah yeah and then they sees it he sees
like a flier somewhere about what the
dates are and he's like yeah which is
creepy because if that Hart guy didn't
do that he might still be out there
maybe not he might be dead right now I
hope he is okay bride did but yeah but
it does seem like they caught the guy in
the most somewhere he did it something
he did it he did it again I got
somewhere else or he didn't do it again
after that yeah my man teenager [ __ ]
teenagers man yeah alright so we've gone
on way too long I think in this on this
true crime girl-scout murder show it's
just kind of depressing yeah I had to
keep good good I'm gonna bathroom and
stuff Jane you getting mad at me cuz had
to go the bathroom
well he had to get well he has to go get
up a go to the bathroom he's going off
on these tangents and I'm trying to get
it that's the show though that's the
show I know but it's like you make me
lose my place like in my notes and then
like I'm sitting there going where the
[ __ ] was I now I do well because I'm the
one that has to edit it so it's for me
it's a pain in the ass for him it's just
all fun and [ __ ] he can just like yep
and then just like drink and then go to
bed and then like I have to sit here and
like cut out all the [ __ ] [ __ ]
hungry yeah you know alright so we're
gonna wrap it up this true crime episode
hope you have enjoyed it hope we're not
too drunk for you guys to have you know
had a good time well [ __ ] cuz you know
man these [ __ ] are gonna be talking
all kinds of [ __ ] that comment section
our show yeah I changed my name I
changed my name you did so everyone know
who you work as they thought you were
just like some random dude well they
they allowed it they got a new feature
on there that allows you to change your
name see I thought you years ago now
years ago is at least on on the format
that I had on my [ __ ] little little
thing I couldn't change your name so
that that name was like from [ __ ] 20
years ago gloom shadow that she was like
from 20 30 years ago yeah but now you
know I got Tom 13 o'clock okay but now
now because it's associated with our
show you you can't say anything like
super embarrassing on the mothership
because I got other channels I got my
troll channels I'll troll the [ __ ] out
of people really don't you have anything
better to do as all trolls I do like to
troll though you know have anything
better to do yeah I got a bad back that
[ __ ] better to do
doesn't mean I'm not control because I
control their patrols I don't draw 24/7
job I don't have time with you you don't
you you you're I've time for that [ __ ]
now I'd be like a 1 on I got I got 1 1
I'll have time for it and - I don't see
the point of it one of my challenge is
Tommy Davis remember Tommy Davis the guy
who got fired for Scientology
yeah and I'll go in there and troll
Scientology [ __ ] out it's just Tommy
Davis is his name well not everybody
these [ __ ] don't know who Tommy
Davis is Tommy well if you're used to be
the second charge Santa you guys have
seen our shows with the angry gay Pope
then you will know who Tommy Wright yes
so sometimes I'll [ __ ] dress up as
time of Davis and go out and [ __ ] with
people about Scientology
all right that's kind of funny I don't
know but it's I intelligence is okay
with me all right so all right so we're
gonna wrap up the show hopefully you
guys enjoyed it like I said if we're
kind of drunk but whatever that happens
every time okay yeah so remember if you
like the show like share subscribe on
all your social media please subscribe
we need more subscribers that's why
we're monetized for looking for more
subscribers come on gotta make money you
know I eventually gotta make money with
the show we make some money now yeah man
I look at some of those channels and
then its mother for ten thousand dollars
a week what the [ __ ] podcast with this
[ __ ] that's a really I look at their
material I'm like their material isn't
that much better than ours
where's my $10,000 a week
oh you're getting all yeah all right
anyway like share subscribe and all your
social media subscribe if you haven't
already if you would like to use
financially support she'll be much
appreciated you go to our patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin our blog 13 o'clock
podcast up wordpress calm and there's a
button in the sidebar to to a PayPal
account if you'd like to have a one-time
donation that would
so much appreciated some of our fans
have done that including Melanie I see
you out there
also if you didn't see our last movie
review
it was Last House on the Left the Wes
Craven movie so check that out yeah you
have an arranger because we just did
that
I know yes we did we did that this is
that's what he's so drunk because we did
the last house and look at working all
day doing this oh you've been working
all day you've been working for a couple
hours
look at how he's trying to like pull
rank anyway so remember our regular
shows come out every Tuesday maybe a
retrospective Kumasi bugger interface
really I'm gonna have to bust a mother
Oh bring it bring it none I'm not
talking about you I'm just talking about
the metaphysical [ __ ] yeah
I'm metaphysic I've metaphysical mother
oh that's a new shirt hat the bust of
metaphysical Miami this [ __ ] up on the
show it's been a while yeah I've been
this [ __ ] up on [ __ ] you were
unmanageable
at this point it's gonna be alright I
can't even end the show look at you you
won't even show that it's gonna be
alright well it it's gonna be alright
we'll find out it in the editing phase
some of this might be patreon only I
don't know yet I'll get ready saying
what are you gonna say regular coming
back one day come what may on Blue Bayou
with the fishing boats and the sales of
food anger [ __ ] than anymore are you
sure I'm gonna can I talk you can talk
go ahead good great great sure close the
show up I'm trying to but you won't stop
talking I'm not talking okay I'm not
talking anyway episodes come out every
Tuesday movie retrospective comes out
every
Friday yeah 13 o'clock matinee which is
new movies in the theater that we review
briefly comes out every Sunday so check
those out if we have if you haven't
already and we are gonna mercifully
bring this painful episode to a close go
to club next week okay we're going to
bed right no okay I'm going to bed we
will see you next time
goodbye see you see you guys
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]